what's something they'll watch this
trailer let's do it yeah ready
we're gonna watch Exodus this channel is
meant to be serious
this is know why he keeps joking I know
I'm sorry I'm trying to be as
professional as possible
hello ladies and gentlemen good evening
my name is Ryan short for Ryan as' right
I'm Adele yes
Adele and no one knows your last name
huh no actually no actually you know
it's not a secret secret yeah what is
your last name you want to say it are
you uncomfortable
hey you're gonna get stalked right now
I'd stalk you dad's dog me I'll try to
now we're gonna watch the trailer today
for Exodus gods and kings now I want to
see this movie because two reasons no
just one
Christian Bale yeah don't you like the
story of the biblical story of Moses and
the plagues and frogs and locusts and
things I know the Moses story I've seen
Prince of Egypt DreamWorks Animation I
like that I like the music in that
mm-hmm and I read the action Bible so
yeah it's a comic book Bible really yeah
it's really good I forgot the real Bible
story yeah it's got the real Bible
stories but you know told for teens to
understand because we're too lazy to
read so did the bridge notes for that
yeah it was talking hurts it's hard I
was a hard book to read Christian Bale
he [ __ ] rocks favorite part of
American hustle was him the fighter come
on man Batman guys sexy American Psycho
and it's directed by a director who used
to mainly do really good films but is
real hit and miss lately release khat oh
yeah you know really Scott is right yeah
Ridley Scott yeah here's the girl in
this um girl is there a girl in this
there's always a kiss a Hollywood movie
this is gonna be a love interest oh I
just have a love interest yeah you got
married and had kids
hey this is gotta be a girl gotta get
your Bible knowledge man look at your
Christianity up Sander you lend me your
Bible comic sure it's in my bedroom can
I show you to my bedroom let's watch
this trailers watches trailer
fine sweetie gonna be a life you say
that you didn't cause all this you say
this is not some folks
so let's just see who's more effective
it kick
[Music]
you only wear my
[Music]
loses ramasees when I look at you I
still see the two boys who grew up
together
meet me down
by the gallery close as brothers
perfectly group facial
I came in to tell you that something is
going that is out of my control
[Music]
Wow
boss hmm that looks worth my time
yeah I want to check it out decaling
Allah Jesus is calling me I didn't see
it but they did reference how Moses and
ramasees grew up together I hope they
don't really include any like cheesy
flashbacks of them as kids you know I
kept a focus on them now as adults yeah
it would be an interesting story to
really have it be based around the rule
because it seems like it's really based
around the relationship between Moses
and Rameses or Xerxes from 300 no I
don't know why Christian Bale has like a
perfect haircut you should have given
him like a longer beard
yeah I thought Moses had like long hair
and long beard what is it why does she
look like a relic room oh yeah yeah he
looks great
I wanted my coffee from him right now
yeah no I I think Christian Bale will
[ __ ] rock it in the role I don't know
who's playing Ramses but you know like
it looks like sort of like 300 but the
Moses version yeah there's CG effects
look pretty cool like that wall of water
oh yeah that was crazy yeah I was like
okay that that sold me right there like
okay that looks pretty real actually do
you know the Moses story well uh I did
see Prince of Egypt in fact I kind of
want to see it right now oh what's that
mean we should watch it right before we
watch this one and then we can compare
the two and see which one's better I do
that yeah I think Prince of Egypt like
when they're erasing their horses up and
down and then you know like going
through the tower and they got like
goofy little servants like that seems a
lot more accurate to me than what we
just saw the chariot stuff yeah no I'm
totally [ __ ] with you it up I don't
know why you think I need works
animation movie is more believable than
that well you know better no I wouldn't
put it past Hollywood
it looks like an epic piece with that is
I don't know if the god stuff is gonna
be subtle I mean it looks like because
the first minute of that trailer was
like just Ramses and Moses and then it
was like gods going crazy on us oh no no
no I think as long as they
guess on that you have human story and
then keep the god stuff is just extra
themes in the background then I think
it'll be a good yeah I'm excited
I'll see how you should make it Ridley
Scott go back to that editing room redo
it all listen to Adele listen to it now
yeah she's Australian know what I'm
talking about yeah do an Australian
accent Ryan alright my name is Moses I
know Australians everywhere are offended
right now no they should feel flattered
they're like you should be the next Hugh
Jackman or something who never plays
Australians yeah cool style hey yeah
jean shorts and converse thanks mo I had
to walk two miles to get here yeah cuz
I'm not a gentleman she's like can you
pick me up and I was like oh you multi
miles
I just bought some food anyway guys if
you're new to the channel subscribe
subscribe and if you want to subscribe
to Adele's Channel she does move your
reviews and such subscribe right here
and that this link is not working
because apparently I don't know what the
[ __ ] I'm doing you can go to the
description box and copy and paste our
link right there
I'm gonna give some shout outs here Jose
Sanchez jr. homeboy wanted to shout out
well Jose it was suppose a I'm a total
racist right now depending don't say
Mexicans your cousin actually could have
been someone else yeah you wanted a
shout out so there's a you're racist
shout out for you buddy Brian Irizarry
last he said I need a shout out well I
don't need one but I would like one well
if you just like a shout out but you
don't need one do I really need to take
the time out to give you your shadow
we'd like to shout out to you Brian oh
you're gonna be all nice about it huh
look look at his display picture it's
kind of erotic a bit you're sure Liz bit
shirtless so it's surely by Brian yeah
oh wow I don't like that she sees I see
6-pack Brian you got a six-pack Brian
damn good for you dude
good for you adèle likey comment on our
videos now think you already do Brian I
think we're already friends yeah maybe
he masturbates to you or something by
the way I know you're still new to the
channel but you got to get used to
comments like that for me I'm talking
dick jokes vagina jokes
masturbation a lot of sex there's a lot
of sex I want my mom to see these videos
um she can watch them Sam I like what
she's hearing who knows I know she's in
a happy marriage right now but hey hey
what's up miss Adele this is Adele how
you doing did you just crack along with
my mom oh yeah no would you say cracking
on it
is that why are you cracking on that a
Aussie phrase yeah hitting on someone Oh
hitting on yes cracking on yeah yeah I'm
cracking on your mom that sounds like
I'm crapping on your mom I'm crap taking
it [ __ ] on your mom no you're a
beautiful woman
I'm definitely showing her this video
yeah please diff yeah Brian keep up the
body Zac zart is a car yes may have a
shot up please you all are awesome yes
Zack shout out shout out crack on you
uh-huh are you into that Orient's of
people crapping on you crapping or
cracking crapping no can you hurry into
people cracking on you depending look
Zack Zack Zacarias look what you've
started
look what you started with your [ __ ]
question for a shout-out now you got her
uncomfortable you got me saying things
like normally say but didn't want to say
today because I'm trying to be polite to
Adele I invite her on here and now look
at this look what you've caused awkward
tension sexual tension that's right it's
getting frisky in here once the camera
stops early you know what I mean it's
gonna be a gonna show her my yachting
keys
doesn't make any sense
I guess the penis would be the God and
the testicles will be the kings I think
you just cut right there my face it's
cut yeah I'm gonna leave this in just
because you said that good night or good
morning